the sun is merciless here
rain is scarce for a long time the
northwest indian climate has been
hostile to residents
rainfall here comes in at barely 750
millimeters a year
only a third of the precipitation that
falls in mumbai further to the south
the situation was once dramatic for the
families living here and their fields
says 55 year old farmer harry ram gadri
he lives with his family in the small
village of batkota
our crops used to dry out and our family
members were constantly worrying about
things like the crops needing water
how to irrigate the fields and where to
get animal feed
things have been transformed now though
partly because of harry ram gadri
he's what's known here as abujal jankar
the hindi name means someone who knows
all about groundwater
twenty bj's as they're nicknamed here
live in the surrounding villages
gadgery regularly checks the water
levels in the wells and records any
trace of rain
i used to feel really strange in front
of the other villagers when i first
started taking the measurements they
used to ask me
what on earth are you doing
every now and then yogita dashora comes
to see hariram gadri
she works for the marvy project run by a
nearby university in udaipur
together with australia's western sydney
university
the project aims to help people find
ways of dealing with the constant water
shortage here
living on location the bj's are key
participants
though they had to be trained up to
handle their tasks
they didn't have any classroom education
till now so
it was new experience for them that how
they they have opportunity to go to
college and learn about things
and though it was like for ten days or
seven days
uh for a six month period but it was big
a big opportunity for them bj's informed
the other villagers about the data
they've gathered
advising them at meetings like this one
most
farmers here used to rely purely on
wheat it was a lucrative crop
but one which consumed huge amounts of
water
now they cultivate a variety of crops
depending on the market situation and
the time of year
to do that they divided their fields
into individual plots
[Music]
we take a piece of land and divide it
into four sections
mustard ashoka flowers and chickpeas
by doing that we have enough water and
we earn more from our crops
anyone who needs water takes some of the
precious groundwater from their own well
of which there are millions in india
getting people to only take a bare
minimum
and leave enough for everyone else was a
challenge for the project
actually before marvi they were working
separately they were digging their own
wells
and they were not concerned about the
quantity of groundwater and they were
just thinking
and water they have water but now they
are thinking that
if we will work together and
cooperatively and share water
among themselves they can help each
other and
can recharge much more water drip
irrigation
a kind of micro irrigation and
sprinklers are also helping now
they mean much less water evaporates or
trickles away unused on the fields
the new agricultural methods mean
farmers here use 70 percent less water
at the department of soil and water
engineering in new dipo
scientists constantly monitor the water
quality in the region
where the bujal jan cars operate
they compare the results from the
various bj's in their respective regions
once a week the australian project
leader links up from western sydney
university
he's glad the project has been so well
received but adds that there's still a
lot to do
[Music]
the important things we want to do in
this project
which still need to be done developing
this
village groundwater cooperatives
bit further so that they become reality
and also we make sure that
farmers are genuinely involved in the
process not
just as a lip service
now another app has arrived which
collates all the data
in hindi as well by special requests
from the bj's
the marvy project was launched eight
years ago in the states of gujarat and
rajasthan
with a planned lifespan of four years
it's been extended several times and
last year
it was decided to broaden its reach to
take in another twenty thousand villages
across seven indian states
you